I ran the marathon when I was 13 years  old you ran a marathon when you were 13.  I mean it was it wasn't good wait it's  got to be bad for your like bones oh it  was most definitely don't doctors say  don't do that when you're young you're  not supposed to like lift weights until  you're like 16 or something yeah no  wonder yeah why did you run a marathon  when you were 13. it was a cool program  in middle school called students from LA  and essentially it's like they take  young kids and they train them to run  the marathon this this is legal yeah it  feels like it should be illegal no it  was weird too because they bet money and  yeah I think I only did it was like  seven hours it took me to fish the  marathon it was a long time okay yeah I  mean it's a [ __ ] time  I was 13 dude